what an e3 it's been Tim oh my god I
think at the top of everyone's list of
amazing [ __ ] they've seen amazing
spectacular with you say I would say old
it's spider-man
oh my descriptors yeah right what do we
think of spider-man so far from what you
guys like it I can put it the footage it
is unbelievable there it is there you
got what do you guys think of the white
spider yeah good good
now Greg Miller over here white smile I
get I since you've debuted
right I understood when insomniac
debuted I totally got it and today when
we were giving our behind-closed-doors
demo from Brian Wright you drove at home
of like we want you to look at and say
oh it's spider-man but see it and say oh
that's not a spider-man I immediately
know I need to understand it who it is
and now it's insomniacs exactly through
I mean for all of our games we work with
our partners we want them to bring their
vision to the game yeah and we want when
they approach the Marvel characters we
want them to be very familiar and
identifiable but also unique and ownable
for each game so when you see spider-man
it's not just any spider-man like that
spider-man or marble spider-man on ps4
yeah we're building a new universe with
insomniac and who's spider-man you're
telling a new story right so we want to
make sure that it still feels right but
it's new and different you don't know
what's gonna happen I mean we did a huge
study of the costume because you know we
we think spider-man is one of the if not
the best designed superhero costumes of
all time damn so if we change anything
we want to understand what the original
suit did what does the red mean what the
blue means the white all the elements
even the spokes on the mask how many
should there be so really we studied it
and before we change anything we just
said how can we analyze it how can we
add something to it but still respect
Stan Lee Steve Ditko Jenner meet a
senior and all the great creators who
made that suit what it is well what I
loved about the Brian talking about
today cuz he's doing the developer thing
we're not talking about this hey we're
not gonna get any shirts from I don't
know give her the secrets I'm
complimenting you we protect the secret
I'm saying what he was saying though
that kind of started bringing me around
on the suit on the white spider yeah it
was he's like it was somebody asked in
the crowd how much Liberty has Marvel
given you get to play with it he's like
well as long as we can justify anything
we're doing that's how we do it it's
like there's a
is it a suit looks like the suit yeah
and so I understand of course I'm saying
stick with me I'm sticking with you Ben
had some kind of white spider business
here was his logo and now he's scheming
on right now Kenan knock handle actually
I'm a side white spider business if you
guys want to buy something are you
selling right wife spider sounds awesome
so my favorite thing is a so Brian the
creative director on the game his
passion was so obvious not only him
talking about the game but showing it in
just every little detail how stoked and
hyped he was for how spider-man it
looked and felt like you can just see
looking at this you're like oh man they
nailed it like in five seconds you're
like they got it right yeah
Brian and the team at insomniac are
incredible they're all like super
passionate about stand and from day one
just immerse themselves in spider-man
and we're lucky because we're just right
down the road from insomniac games our
office is like 10 minutes away from
their office so we don't I once or twice
a week to visit them we get to see stuff
in progress we get to talk about the
story we get to talk about the gameplay
we talk about the suit design and it's
not just for the show it's palpable
every day yeah in there how much they
love spider-man and how much they care
we all care so deeply about everybody
remembers when they first met spider-man
their first experience with spider-man I
that cardboard standee of spider-man in
my bedroom growing up I was an artist in
a former life which still hangs by the
way in my mom's seventh grade classroom
um and so anytime is a very important
character to everybody like none of that
is lost on on anybody and insomnia kinda
shows yeah I mean the the the first
lunch we got together we were sitting
around talking about hey when's the
first time you experienced spider-man
and we all realized that we were all six
years old all had the same spider-man
underoos yeah yeah we have loved this
character all our lives and we really
live and breathe that idea of power and
responsibility and Bill's son's name is
Peter just in case you had any question
of loss dedication we're talking about
yeah yeah so now we jump right into this
it's e3 we're excited spider-man what I
don't didn't do a good job for everybody
watching at home is explained who you
guys are
oh yeah let's rewind it oh girl are cool
I mean yeah so we're marble games yep
we're out here
Glendale we out here we're about two and
a half years ago yeah they kind of
reassembled the Marvel games team I came
from the East Coast I've been lucky
enough to be working with Marvel in
publishing since the early 90s I started
writing for Marvel Age magazine and then
I joined the staff and became a
copywriter than sort of writing comics
and then started editing comics had that
long run and bills being modest he
edited all the guardians of the galaxy
comics that became the inspiration for
the film's yeah he did that ta kid bill
right so I remember rocky became modest
when I was 14 and there was that rocket
racoon miniseries and I said I want to
bring him back everyone made fun of me
yeah I said come on he's short he's
furry he'll be our Wolverine he's a
rocket with a big gun in the jet pack
what's not to like attitude yeah yeah
well you made it happen and then the
call came to read some of the games team
and I wanted to work with this guy so I
jet it out here and Mike Jones came from
two decades of building games traveling
the world so I you know I'm lifelong
Marvel fan and worked in game
development game publishing my whole
career and never thought I would ever
get a chance to work on Marvel
properties or games and and you know I
worked at Capcom for a while which was a
brush with Marvel's yeah but then yet
two and a half years ago this
opportunity came up and Marvel was
getting really serious about like hey
our game should be awesome as awesome as
all of our other entertainment from
movies TV publishing so we're like all
right let's do it let's partner with the
best in the business here we are here we
are
and for years people like when we joined
I like where your big games were the
console games with it's like it takes
time son you have to get it about a
that's the thing is it's like that time
and energy is gonna pay off it's already
starting to pay off
I remember when Greg and I got to go see
Avengers 2 back in the day and it was
because the Marvel games got us in and
there was this whole presentation before
and they're like we are Marvel games
this is our future we are building
towards this we're partnering with
telltale for this we're doing like all
these different partnerships and now to
see spider-man with insomniac TV
Avengers with a square yeah it's like
we're building this this games
Marvel games universe that is so
exciting and sure I feel that the
quality control is
is the most important thing and that's
obviously a guys that's what takes a
time you know we don't want to rush
anything out we don't want to do
spider-man the game that's a game based
on the movie and rush it out for a movie
window it's not we're about we're like
let's just make the best spider-man game
and release it when it's wealthy and
yeah and think of gaming as it's not a
derivative business it's a another
pillar of the brand you know people you
know the movies come out twice a year
starting three times a year this year we
have our Netflix shows TV shows that
people love to binge and watch comics
people read the comics weekly monthly
but people are playing our games every
day and experience our characters
stories every day it's an opportunity to
tell new stories engage with fans in
different ways introduce them to new
characters they may not know about as
you've seen mr. negative Martin Lee
Miles Morales Yuri Watson ah Bay right
we're going to keep mixing it up but
games is a very very important
destination now for Marvel storytelling
Marvel fans and the quality you've come
to know and love from that Marvel brick
right right we want you to see that
Marvel logo on a game package would be
like oh it's gonna be awesome
yeah seeing writer negative in this game
I think is such a huge selling point
because that shows that it is not just
the Green Goblin story we've done a
million times this is really for fans
and I think even for people that aren't
necessarily the hardcore spider-man's
it's a good introduction yeah a wider
world I know who he is but you're gonna
learn that we want to mix it up and
we're really inspired by like looking at
our next Netflix shows and you see
Jessica Jones and most people did not
know like what's a kilgrave what's a
purple man yeah we knew what a problem
was and they really put the spotlight on
him in elevators so cool and so we
thought this is our opportunity to you
know we're going to have a lot of
familiar faces in this game but why not
Pitt character that we believe in it's
only been in comics for the past five to
six years but we believe has a great
potential let's put the spotlight on him
let's elevate him and then the world
would be like I love mr. daggett he's
awesome which to be clear was not it's
not like we for we like oh this game has
said mr. daga that was Brian and a team
coming to us being like we wanted we
want to take this character and put our
spin on it and like introduce them to
the world then we're like hell yeah
let's do it that's an issue how does how
did these partnerships start you guys
two and a half years ago we're bringing
Marvel games together
good stuff is it you then going to
insomniac isn't it's on me I come it's
you music and lyrics man like so
sometimes both sometimes you write the
music firstly sometimes partners come to
us and they're like hey we have an
awesome pitch for a game we have a
really cool idea we'll talk about it
we'll high-five or rock and roll
sometimes we're like we really respect
this develop we really respect you know
what these developers do these creatives
do in this space this genre or whatever
it is we think this will be a good fit
we go proactively talk to them so we're
we're actively planning what our
portfolio looks like what types of games
were making what platforms they're on
we're looking at mobile console pc vr
all kinds of stuff right and we want to
put the best characters and franchises
and experience on the best platforms
with the developers that are best at
doing that stuff and that's the that's
the fun that we get to have is we're not
just one developer or one publisher we
get to go out and work with the best of
the best right and I think you mentioned
it earlier about some of the
announcements we made towards the end of
last year and this year our partnership
with insomniac and Playstation right are
telltale guardians of the galaxy series
bring it back Marvel vs. Capcom and our
Square Enix partnership with Crystal
Dynamics and Avengers game and people
without us saying anything immediately
like four corners made a square and
they're like oh we see what they're
doing they're serious yeah right and
this is a very historic III I feel like
I'm rambling now but this is a very
historic III for us because we've been
you know with our with our partners
insomniac Capcom Lego telltale we've
been working really really hard to bring
some awesome content to the fore and to
have three big games at this conference
have our telltale series going on have
two games and Sony's press conference
and have spider-man close out the show
what an honored slot like it's
incredible right and and and say but
it's just the beginning oh that's so
exciting the room today when we did saw
the demo there was an energy where it's
just like as it was happening we just
kept looking at each other being like
this is so cool it's just you're nailing
it in the you see the demo or whether
it's you know in behind closed doors or
what we saw at the conference and it's
like right that's what a spider-man game
should look and feel like yeah when you
come in that first time and she's like
you
this he's like yeah I got this I got
this it's right into pop pop pop and
using new gadgets doing all the stuff
that we haven't done in a spider-man
game before is right this better man
he's a he's been fighting crime for
about eight years he's experienced
he's like an athlete at the top of his
game and like you're right he he'll have
yer say do you have this and he makes it
oh yeah I got this I got this but then
in true spider-man fashion a few mins II
don't go like oh yeah right before he
went yeah I got don't screw this up
right yeah you know yeah so really yes
he's gonna be experienced but we're
never forgetting the humor of spider-man
that's part of the reason why we
partnered with insomniac on it because
they really bring the humor they bring
the personality and the humor that
spider-man has it's it's I say it's
almost part of his powers you know he
could stick to walls he has a spider
sense he has the agility has a strength
and web-swing he builds hills web stone
for your webs got his mind and he also
uses humor as a weapon when he's
fighting a foe that may be more powerful
that than him that's older than him to
get them off their game he may use humor
but he always uses it with himself - yes
we do as we go through our daily lives
and we kind of that voice in our head as
we talk to ourselves so I hope you'll
see that that fun yeah John and humor it
got it all you guys got it that's the
thing is like when I was watching the
demo like yeah the the parts we had seen
you know don't screw this up and all
that but there was in the behind
closed-doors demo a sec a part where
there was a steel beam that was on a
chain right and they you could have give
awkward a ride yeah dad you want that
and did that doesn't hit them all like
can everyone do that like oh that's why
there's humour in combat yep I mean if
you look closely and hopefully everybody
will get a chance to go in a theater
because they're playing it differently
in there they're trying different things
yeah a little web trap that he uses you
can actually use it between two guys
know they'll pop together when you web
them up with the impact webs
you can when you in the demo that we
showed at the press conference he knocks
them up in 6 into a wall you can swing
them around second I stuck a guy to a
parking meter one time or to a car that
was driving by and so it gets really
really sort of dynamic and organic when
you start getting in there messing with
all your spider powers and your tech and
your web abilities but everything that
we haven't really shown much of but we
get asked a lot about is that human side
that Peter Parker side I mean game is
very much going to show
bill loves to talk about how the best
spider-man stories are the ones where
Peters and spider-man's worlds collide
right that's actually one of the reasons
why mr. negative is such a great villain
because his philanthropists persona
Martin Lee where Aunt May works at his
feast shelters yeah and mr. negative as
a super villain foil to spider-man it's
just a perfect nexus of we're going to
bring Peter and spiders man's worlds
together anyway you've never seen in a
game right that the original spider-man
creators were so smart before they made
superhero comics you know Stan Lee Steve
Ditko gentleman a senior they were
working on like teen romance comic oh
yeah right so when they created the
first spider-man comics they didn't
leave that behind it was revolutionary
in that it was a superhero story and
they brought that soap opera element
drama it and you had that awesome
supporting cast and as Mike said the
best stories are where Peters civilian
lies that he's trying to protect are in
danger because of his costume lives and
they're smashing together so here you
know Peter and and every spider-man
story is a Peter Parker story he's
always Peter and he's always spider-man
and this one these worlds collide you
have to make decisions like wait if
Martin Lee is mr. negative do I take him
down that's gonna ruin Aunt May's life
because she's finding meaning all
writers life her life or y'all or or or
what if he volunteered the soup shelter
isn't like everything it gives her
meaning it gives her purpose library but
more importantly what if Martin Lee
finds out who he is yeah then is she
gonna be in danger yeah it's great
escalation of drama that and world's
climb that only I think come in a truce
but I'm afraid that story I think is one
of the main reasons we're so excited
about it thank you for bringing it by
2018 correct 28 shooter don't you better
hit 28 Tina I'm sick of waiting already
oh it's like spider mites Amy don't mess
this up don't let this up
tell screw this up it up unanimously
right absolutely
kind of funny approved games yeah yeah
you need to go give this to insomniac
and take a photo with them all right
we'll do it oh [ __ ]
one of our can we get a round of
applause one of our there you go God
thank you congratulations guys that you
should thank you Andrew we've been we've
been waiting a long time to do this
we've talked about getting on the show
and we've been hard at work on Spidey
and Capcom and everything else but thank
you so much for thank you gotta make it
up you guys on the game's cap on the big
stage here all right I'll be done thank
you all right now get off sorry thank
you for you guys thank you our first of
many segments to Marvel games
I can't wait for spider-man oh my god it
looks too good it's unbelievable yeah